fear of terrorism is widespread in
America many Americans have actually
changed how they live their daily lives
a significant number of Americans say
they avoid sporting events concerts and
other public events because of their
fear of terrorism let me ask you a
question
what are people most afraid of you may
think it's insects or natural disasters
or even public speaking but an extensive
survey conducted by Chapman University
in 2015 said the biggest fears and
Americans are cited as the quote manmade
disasters these fears include bio
warfare terrorism and nuclear attacks
44% of Americans are afraid or very
afraid of terrorist attacks compare that
to 28% for public speaking and 25% for
insects fear terrorism actually peaked
following 9/11 as the majority of
Americans were worried that they or
someone they knew would be a victim of a
terrorist attack I want to suggest that
what the public fears is mirrored in
Hollywood cinema especially the zombie
movies directly following 9/11 but to
start we have to go back in time to the
horror movies of the 1950s so let me
rephrase the first question what were
people most afraid of in say 1951 we all
know the atomic bomb is very dangerous
since it may be used against us we must
get ready for it with the Korean War
Soviet nuclear testing and McCarthyism
in full force a 1950 poll showed an
astounding 68 percent of Americans
thought the Soviet Union would use an
atomic weapon against the United States
this fear was even used later as a scare
tactic in an infamous campaign ad by
Lyndon Johnson showing just how powerful
the fear was on the public these are the
stakes to make a world in which all of
God's children can live hard to go into
the dark
we must either love each other or we
must die so how did horror movies
reflect this fear the 1950s brought on a
wave of disaster movies where aliens or
monsters attack like War of the Worlds
the blob and the thing from another
world when you watch battle scenes from
the original War of the Worlds or attack
of the 50-foot woman or Godzilla you
notice the parallels between these
horror movies and the destructive nature
of the atomic bomb in fact the director
of Godzilla was very blunt about his
intentions with the now iconic monster
he said quote the theme of the film from
the beginning was the terror of the bomb
mankind had created the bomb and now
nature was going to take revenge on
mankind for Americans however the fear
was channeled towards the Soviet Union
our biggest global threat at the time in
the same way that Godzilla stomps on
buildings and is immune to bullets so
too would an atomic bomb wipe out cities
and be entirely unstoppable by us maybe
it's no coincidence that the Japanese
film Godzilla was such a huge success in
America the Japanese fear of the bomb
was just as relevant to Americans at the
time now let's jump to the 21st century
we're no longer threatened by a huge
visible global superpower actually the
fear of terrorism is quite the opposite
it's nothing like Godzilla a giant
monster who drops in on a city a
terrorist hides in the shadows disguises
themselves as an everyday citizen and
cause a society to collapse from the
inside out so here's my point
doesn't the method of destruction for a
terrorist sound a lot like the method of
destruction for a zombie first it's
important to note the explosion of the
zombie genre io9 posted a nice graph
showing a boom in zombie movies in the
early 2000s paralleling with mainstream
video games like Resident Evil and call
of duty and spilling into other media
like the TV show The Walking Dead
there's no doubt that zombies have
infected the public conscience 28 days
later is one of the first successful
zombie movies to come out following 9/11
and it highlights contemporary fears of
terrorism and decay of social order the
scene that most strongly ties the movie
to terrorist fears is actually the very
first scene the deadly virus is created
in a lab by making chimpanzees watch
footage of Arabic mobs fighting police
burning cars and beating each other up
this virus is literally created from
arabic violence i particularly like this
shot which makes the human look like
it's regressing back into a terrifying
animal and
element of the zombie genre is that the
enemy comes inside a community and
spreads from person to person
this sounds eerily similar to the method
of attack for a terrorist a sleeper cell
hides within our borders ready to strike
and once we can finally spot it it's too
late to stop I think another key
difference between 50s monster movies
and zombie movies is the role of the
government in monster movies the
government often fights against the
enemy but in 28 days later the
government has abandoned them but the
government what do they do there's no
government of course is a government
there's always a government they're in a
bunker or a plane there's no government
please not only that but in the movie
the soldiers actually fight against the
protagonist in the 21st century with the
controversial invasion of Iraq and
government surveillance terrorism has
brought on a distrust of our own
government where the 1950s government
was always joining in the fight against
a common enemy
it appears that during a zombie
apocalypse we shouldn't count on any
government to protect us what's so
special about cinema is that it's such a
democratic art form when it comes to art
forms like painting music or creative
writing the message is only channel
through one person but with cinema the
final work is the product of dozens of
people not only that but a production
process as expensive as making a movie
requires that mainstream movies appeal
to as many people as possible as a
result movies tend to be a window into
the general mindset of the society it
was made in this means that the subject
matter of a successful horror movie has
in its subtext a reflection of the
general fears of the environment it was
made in there are things that regardless
of time period and society humans are
scared of the dark is a universal fear
because we can't identify the threat so
a movie like don't breathe seems to do
well because like jaws and the ending of
Silence of the Lambs it's scary when the
threat can see you but you can't see
that it's a timeless fear but what about
fears that do change over time I talked
about monster movies versus zombie
movies but I also think mainstream
horror movies about religion are another
perfect example religion is at an
all-time low in the United States more
importantly the fear of damnation is low
meaning that religious groups tend to
spend less time on the pain and torment
of Hell in their teachings and more time
on the love and forgiveness that comes
from salvation this idea is especially
true in the Catholic Church who revised
their Catechism in 1994
to remove the literary
fire-and-brimstone description of hell
in favor of a metaphorical place
symbolizing the loss of one's faith so
how is this idea shown in modern movies
around 40 or so years ago most movies
about the supernatural centred around
religion the devil is often the center
villain in successful movies like
Rosemary's Baby The Omen and The
Exorcist
nowadays those supernatural beings are
still present but religion is largely
ignored the ghost is a former mental
patient or some unexplained being The
Exorcist is about a child being
possessed by the devil orphan has a very
similar premise a child who is acting
strangely but religion is hardly even
mentioned the fact is that people don't
find a double as scary as they used to
partly due to less religion and partly
due to a conscious choice to focus less
on damnation in religious doctrine
there's no doubt that there are
detectable trends in what horror movies
choose to find scary if you want to know
what people are afraid of you could run
an expensive and time-consuming
statistical study or you could just look
at what horror movies they find scary so
the next time someone says don't be
scared it's just a movie don't believe
them thanks for watching here it is the
cool slightly transform just a bit of a
break from the norm just a little
something to break the monotony of all
that